ustedes parecen defender dos posiciones
que dividen el derecho a decidir y
pertenecen a una organización católica
como se reconcilian justamente estas dos
posturas
y valentina muchas gracias se reconcilia
antes de un principio básico del
catolicismo que es el respeto por la
conciencia de las personas y el respeto
por la conciencia es un principio de la
enseñanza católica que dice que
que habrá sobre la conciencia como
árbitro final de cualquier decisión
moral que tomemos como personas la
conciencia incluye el conocimiento de
nosotros mismos y la conciencia de
nuestros principios morales y el impulso
de actuar y desde allí nosotras
partimos para decir que las decisiones
que cada persona tome sobre su cuerpo
competen a su conciencia y cuando se
trata de realizarse un procedimiento
médico como el aborto es una decisión
que compete a la persona a su conciencia
y al profesional médico que las está
asistiendo entonces desde ahí desde
nuestra desde nuestra fe y no a pesar de
nuestra fe nosotras
defendemos en las libertades
reproductivas incluido el derecho al
aborto desde esta visión que ustedes
defienden cómo quedaría la situación de
las mujeres en eeuu si se concreta la
anulación que pasa justamente con ese
derecho a decidir
claro pues esto lo que lo que
ocasiona es que el derecho al aborto ya
no es
una vez se haga oficial no sería un
derecho protegido por la constitución
y entonces cada estado podría determinar
cuál es la regulación sobre este
procedimiento médico anular esta
sentencia significa que
alrededor de 26 estados podrían moverse
rápidamente a prohibir el aborto
incluidos tres estados con leyes que
podrían entrar en vigencia de inmediato
eso significa que la mitad del país la
gente ya que ya tenía derechos y que los
ha tenido por los últimos 50 años pues
no los tiene y eso es particularmente
preocupante para la comunidad latina en
particular porque ya tenemos unos unas
barreras al acceso a la salud
que son evidentes
muchas de ellas tienen que ver con
con navegar un sistema que es bastante
diferente al de nuestros países en
latinoamérica navegar un sistema a otro
idioma y ahora pues obviamente eso y
esto tiene una interno lugar de
intersección importante con la movilidad
porque
las en los estados que no permitan el
aborto las personas que van a buscar
este procedimiento se van a movilizar
hacia los estados que sí están brindando
el servicio y esto pues va a poner una
carga desproporcionada bueno justamente
qué dice esto del avance o retroceso de
la sociedad estadounidense en materia de
derechos
si nosotras tenemos claro que no
solamente las personas católicas porque
hay estudios que demuestran que
alrededor del 68 por ciento de las
personas católicas del país apoyan el
acceso al aborto entonces no nuevamente
no son no son ideas contrarias
por el contrario y la mayoría de
personas en el país apoyan el acceso al
aborto como un procedimiento médico
entonces para nosotras es muy grave
porque el pueblo estadounidense
apoya este derecho y como lo dijimos
pues es algo que es un retroceso de 50
años en materia de derechos sexuales y
reproductivos